the thick jungle of northern Miramar
offers the soldiers of the kitchen army
some protection but only some but they
use this cover tirelessly because
they're fighting for their very
existence this part of Myanmar which is
home to the kitchen people is cut off to
aid agencies politicians and foreigners
but we managed to get rare access with
the help of one of Myanmar's toughest
rebel groups the kitchen army are a
battle-hardened mostly Christian outfit
and they're convinced the Burmese troops
want to eliminate them altogether the
kitchen people have faced random
indiscriminate attacks like this from
the Burmese military for years
but fresh off their bloody campaign
against the ring the Muslims the Myanmar
troops have launched a fresh offensive
against the kitchen
[Applause]
the Miramar military are using the same
tactics they've unleashed against the
Ranga burning homes and forcing
terrified families to run for their
lives the mode of escape may be
different in this area but the modus
operandi of the brutal oppressor is
horrifyingly similar hundreds of
civilians have been trapped in the
jungle unable to return to their homes
and cornered by Miramar troops
Lachi and her children are amongst tens
of thousands now living in camps her
families fled from Myanmar treats seven
times and she's in no doubt what they're
trying to do to the kitchen I'm
convinced the Burmese government's
trying to carry out ethnic cleansing if
the kitchen people whenever they see
kitchen civilians they kill them if they
see a kitchen woman they'll rape her
the organizers say even the camps are
attacked the Burmese military attack
again
to the king and they have to move to get
here no one here feels secure bombing
civilians and safe havens is a war crime
under international law many of the
families here have fled attacks more
than once jumping from Camp to camp to
try and find safety and always living in
these very very basic conditions where
the houses are extremely flimsy so after
fighting for self autonomy for decades
the kichan army is bedding in for this
fresh onslaught from the old enemy they
have well established defense positions
but they're hemmed in by the Burmese
military and troops see one soldier in
the center and a larger group of
soldiers to the right of your screen
moving behind the trees there are
numerous positions like this one from
where they attack the kitchen at random
he's showing me how you can see the me
and more military there are only about
800 meters away positioned right on the
top and that's where they mount some of
these attacks through day and night the
Katyn army defend their territory
their small arms are no match against
the miramar military's air power and
artillery and their leaders are clear
the Myanmar military guilty of war
crimes and this country's former British
colonizers
know that but ignore it now gone and in
words we see them carrying a lot of
crimes against humanity
there are many unlawful arrests there's
a real abuse of power and they are
intentionally forcing people out of
their homes and making them move they're
busy recruiting all the time to their
[Applause]
this luck started training a week ago
they tell you here that the atrocities
suffered by the rahega have been endured
in secret by the kichan for decades
there are hundreds of these camps all
over Kachin territory and those inside
believed because the international
community chose to ignore their hunger
crisis the Myanmar authorities are now
turning on the country's other ethnic
groups like the kitchen with vigor
Alex Crawford Sky News in northern mia
mark